a fairy senior a very well respected and
very high profile detective Chief
Inspector here in Oma was the victim of
this gun attack this cold and calculated
attack it was at a targeted attack at
this Sports Club on the outskirts of oma
town and the PSI also revealed other
details he was with his young son at the
time of this incident he was putting
footballs into the boot of his car when
two masked men approached in the car
park here at this Sports Club an opened
fire he was hit repeatedly he fell to
the ground and he was shot again you can
only imagine how traumatic it must have
been for not only his son but the many
other children that had just finished a
training session here of of which the
detective Chief Inspector was a
voluntary coach when this attack
unfolded and we've been getting local
reaction here throughout the morning as
well as uh late last night as well and
I'm joined Now by a local mp uh Shin
fein's MP for West Throne Orla thanks
for speaking to Sky news this morning or
I mean everybody here is still absorbing
this but how in your dealings with the
community so far how are people taking
this this is a throwback to another
Northern Ireland
well I have to say this is a very
callous grotesque attack last night and
my thoughts first and foremost are with
the police officer I'm wishing him a
fall on speedy recovery I'm also
thanking up his family at this time and
they must be traumatized by this
incident last night particularly his
young son and my thoughts are with them
this morning the people here are just in
a State of Shock and displayed that this
would happen in their local community
this is a safe place here it's a local
community Hub where people come and to
enjoy their Sports and it should be a
safe place for all particularly for
children and young people that were here
last night unfortunately that was not
the case and this morning we're joining
in condemnation office there's no place
for violence in our society and that is
a clear message coming from Kelly
clarker here today
and the Police Service of Northern
Ireland also this morning told us that
the primary focus is dissident
republicanism now that when you hear a
police officer is being targeted or
being shot in Northern Ireland it is the
Hallmarks of dissident Republicans who
want to Target and they want to murder
police officers
honey with your broader experience of
the Republican Community are they
reversed
well I have to say there's absolutely no
support for violence here in Uma and
that's been shown time and time again
we're coming up to the 25th anniversary
um off the Good Friday agreement and
what we want to look towards is a bright
and better future for everyone living in
this local community we can see today
that political leaders are here this
morning indeed there's Community leaders
there's local school leaders as well and
we're all joining us as one and
condemning what happened here last night
and that remains the approach there is
no place for violence in our society in
this day and age
unequivocally condemned this we
condemned right and utterly there's no
place for balance there's no place for
this to have taken place last night and
that remains the case this morning why
do some extreme elements of the
Republican Community feel that they are
entitled to carry out these attacks to
try and drag Northern Ireland back to a
very dark past
big for them but
but my generation have benefited so
greatly from The Good Friday agreement
and we want to ensure that we heal the
wounds of the past but we move together
as one and look towards brighter days
ahead